You are warmly welcome to this deep dive into a pretty harsh but profoundly transformative reality.
Yeah, harsh is definitely the word I'd use.
I mean, I want you to imagine spending your entire life following every single rule of your religion perfectly.
Just doing everything exactly by the book.
Exactly.
You observe the rituals, you memorize the texts, you do all the physical motions prescribed to you, do absolutely everything asked of you by the visible tradition, and then
you're told that despite all of that flawless observance, you're still operating at the spiritual level of a beast.
Which is just a staggering thought.
It fundamentally shakes how we understand religious practice.
It really does.
But that is the exact unyielding scenario we are unpacking today from a remarkable text known as the Master and the Disciple.
It originates from 10th century Yemen.
And it doesn't hold back at all.
Not even a little.
What this text does is lay out a strict foundational architecture of knowledge.
It doesn't just divide knowledge into the known and the unknown.
It presents a three-layer structure.
So you have the outer aspect, the inner aspect, and the inner of the inner.
And what makes this geometry so compelling and frankly so demanding is that these three dimensions map perfectly onto 3 levels of creatures.
Right, which are beasts, humans, and angels.
And before we get into the mechanics of that mapping, I want to plant the core thesis that anchors this entire system.
This is the absolute spine of the text.
The ladder is real.
The highest rung cannot be transferred, only earned.
And just to clarify our lens for this deep dive before we go further, we are looking at a classical Ismaili reading of this architecture.
That's A crucial positionality note.
Yeah, because this framework has significant overlap with the broader Sufi tradition and its dedicated search for inward meaning, but it maintains a very sharp structured distinction from the Sunni juristic difference.
We're examining a highly specific spiritual geometry here.
We are.
But looking at that architecture, as a seeker, I have an immediate crisis with it.
Like the disciple in the text experiences this firsthand.
Tell me about that.
I mean.
I can easily understand an outer layer and an inner layer, but does the inner actually have an innermost dimension?
And more importantly, if this highest angelic rung exists, is it actually climbable by a human being or is it permanently sealed off from human reach?
That is the big question, isn't it?
Is.
And frankly, I have to challenge the necessity of climbing at all.
Like, why isn't mere observance of the rules sufficient?
You mean just following the visible practices?
Yeah, let's say a person observes all the
visible practices, lives an orderly life, fulfills their communal obligations perfectly.
Why do they need to seek out these hidden layers?
Why is the outer not enough?
Well, because treating mere observance as enough completely collapses the latter.
The text counters this assumption with a very stark, almost clinical warning, if you know only the outer aspect of the physical world.
Just reciting names and observing rituals.
Yeah, exactly.
If you do that without ever asking what those things point to, you leave yourself operating at the level of beasts.
The tradition calls this strictly visible surface, Zahir.
That is a brutally harsh categorization for someone who is simply following the rules they were taught.
It sounds harsh, but it's not meant as a moral insult.
It's a precise description of cognitive limitation.
Think about how an animal interacts with a physical space.
A beast encounters a physical barrier like a brick wall, but it doesn't understand the concept of architecture or property lines or the purpose of a house.
It just registers the physical stimulus.
Exactly.
It merely registers it.
If a human being only engages with the visible forms of their tradition, they're doing the exact same thing.
They're simply registering spiritual stimuli.
They memorize the shapes of the letters or the motions of the prayer, but entirely miss the architecture.
Yes.
They're trapped in a world of mere reaction, which is the defining characteristic of a beast.
Okay, that makes sense conceptually, but I have to push back here.
That sounds like clever wordplay.
Yeah, I mean, isn't this just relabeling 2 layers as three?
You have a visible action and you have the hidden intention behind it.
Asserting a third layer of the inner just feels like multiplying layers for poetic effect.
I completely understand why you'd argue that.
It's the natural skepticism of anyone looking at esoteric philosophy.
It sounds profound, but does it actually exist in reality?
Right.
It's very easy to assume that mystical texts just pile on layers to sound more profound or exclusive.
But the author anticipates this exact assumption and steel mans it.
He dismantles it completely by walking through three specific nested proofs
to show this triple structure isn't just poetry.
Okay, let's walk through those proofs then, because if this geometry is foundational, it should be universally applicable.
It is.
The first analogy uses a very tangible physical reality drawn directly from the Quran.
Specifically, chapter 7, verse 26, which discusses clothing.
When you break down the reality of what clothing is, you find 3 distinct layers that cannot be collapsed into two.
First, you have the physical fabric you wear.
The part that is visible to everyone, like the wool or the cotton.
Yes, that is the outer aspect.
But why do you wear it?
The verse moves to the second layer, which is the covering of what is private.
That's the inner aspect.
It's the function or the purpose of the visible fabric.
Exactly.
The fabric is merely serving a hidden necessity, which is modesty or the concealment of the body.
If you stop there, you have your two layers.
the fabric and the function of the fabric.
Which is usually where our everyday understanding stops, the action and the intention behind it.
But the verse doesn't stop there.
It introduces 1/3 layer, the garment of piety.
That is the absolute deepest spiritual principle toward which the physical clothing is merely pointing.
It is the inner of the inner.
It's the ultimate orientation of the soul that necessitates the modesty, which in turn necessitates the fabric.
So without the garment of piety, the covering becomes purely social.
And without the covering, the fabric becomes useless.
Precisely.
One verse, one everyday image, but three nested, indivisible meanings.
All 3 must exist.
That makes the mechanism incredibly clear for a physical object.
You move from the object to its immediate function to its ultimate spiritual root.
But what about outside of physical objects?
Like how we think and communicate?
That's where the second proof comes in.
It moves to the intellectual proof through the mechanism of grammar itself.
Take a simple three-word observation, the moon rose.
A standard sentence.
We use grammatical structures like that 100 times a day.
Yeah, but look at the invisible architecture of how we derive understanding from it.
The text breaks it down into 3 necessary pillars.
The word moon is the name.
The action rose is the attribute.
But the actual physical disk in the night sky
The celestial body itself is the meaning.
Okay, let me see if I can trace that logic.
If you just have the physical disc in the sky without a name, it is something seen but completely unnamable.
You couldn't communicate it to anyone else.
Precisely.
And if you have the name moon without the actual disc existing in reality, it is just a hollow sound with no reference point.
And the attribute rose without either the name or the meaning is just a verb hanging in empty space.
It signifies an action, but there's no actor and no subject.
You got it.
You need the signifier, the attribute, and the essence.
None of these three can function in isolation.
And so the text is mapping this grammatical necessity directly onto the structure of religion.
Exactly.
The literal words recited or physical actions performed are the name.
The spiritual states and functions those names point to in the believer's life are the attributes, and the innermost level is the true meaning, the divine essence.
You cannot collapse it into two, just as you can't have a sentence with only a noun and a verb, no underlying reality.
Okay, so we've done fabric and grammar.
Yeah, but language is man-made and clothing is man-made.
Does this triple layer structure exist organically in nature?
It does, and that brings us to the most biological proof in the text.
Picture an egg sitting on a table.
The text identifies the shell as the outer aspect.
The hard, visible exterior protecting what's inside.
Right.
Then you have the white, which is the inner aspect, the protective liquid layer sitting beneath the cover.
But finally, you have the yolk.
The yolk being the inner of the inner.
Yes, the innermost core.
It's the true substance, the biological center from which life actually originates.
Shell, white, yolk, outer, inner, innermost.
It's not a poetic choice.
structural necessity for life to exist.
If you remove any one of those layers, it ceases to be an egg and life cannot germinate.
And it's vital to ground this.
in its academic context because it shows how pervasive this thinking was.
It wasn't just an isolated metaphor.
Far from it.
Scholars like Henry Corbin in his work, Cyclical Time and Smiling Gnosis, point out that this triple structure is the architecture under which every single verse of scripture was read in this tradition.
And Anna-Ri Schimmel in Mystical Dimensions of Islam demonstrates that this exact same three-fold reading spans well beyond one specific circle.
Yeah, it reaches deeply into wider mystical traditions.
Corbin and Schimmel both confirm that the disciple is being inducted into a massive shared intellectual architecture that governed how entire civilizations understood reality.
And that brings us to the crucial pivot in the text.
We've established the structure of knowledge with the three layers, but how does this map onto the structure of who is doing the knowing, like we mentioned beasts earlier?
The mapping is a direct one-to-one sequence.
We said the outer aspect belongs to beasts.
They interact only with the shell.
The middle layer, the strictly human level of knowing, belongs to the true descendants of Adam.
That's the space where human consciousness actively engages with the inner meaning behind the visible world.
Yes, the space of Baden.
And the highest layer belongs to the angels.
This represents the rung of the prophets, the vice adjurants who are placed on Earth.
They operate at Baden al-Baten.
What is genuinely fascinating here is the cosmological context for why the ladder runs in this exact sequence.
Why does human intellect sit perfectly wedged between the beasts and the angel?
It feels like we need to understand the mechanism behind the ladder itself.
Yeah.
To understand that, we have to draw on the 10th century Fatimid thinker Al-Sijistani.
His profound cosmology, which has been beautifully reconstructed by modern scholar Khalil Andani, explains the origin of human thought.
It's a brilliant framework.
It really is.
In this framework, a God's creative act is not direct in the physical realm.
It is mediated through a first intellect.
So the intellect inside a human being isn't just a biological accident.
It's actually a trace, a direct remnant of that first intellect.
So human consciousness is literally a piece of the original creative force embedded in a physical form.
Exactly.
And this explains the entire purpose of the ladder.
Climbing the ladder is simply the mechanism of that trace turning back toward its origin.
Like a compass needle finding north.
Yes.
The beast level knower possesses the trace but leaves it pointed firmly at the ground.
The human level knower turns it inward toward the meaning, but the angelic level knower, the prophet, has turned that intellect all the way back toward its absolute divine origin.
That is why climbing the ladder is fundamentally an act of return.
And this raises a glaring, honestly uncomfortable question.
When you map humanity onto these rungs, doesn't it create a rigid caste system?
It sounds like a spiritual hierarchy that could easily justify leaving a vast majority of humanity behind in the dirt.
Are people permanently locked into thirds, beasts, humans, angels?
The text absolutely refuses to let this become a permanent sorting of mankind into rigid castes.
It clarifies that there are only two real human categories actively on this path.
Okay, what are they?
To explain this, it quotes the commander of the faithful, peace be upon him, from the peak of eloquence.
This comes from his deeply intimate advice to his student Kumail.
He says there is the sanctified scholar, the teacher whose spirit is firmly connected to certainty.
And the second category.
The seeker.
The learner who is actively walking upon the path of salvation.
So just the scholar and the seeker.
Yeah, the Alem Rabani and the seeker.
But what about the rest of humanity, the people who aren't seeking it all?
That book is utterly unsparing in its description.
It refers to the unsought as the screaming rabble.
The screaming rabble, that is a brutal description.
It is brutal, but it's psychologically profound.
They are described as people who follow every wind, swayed by every loud voice, precisely because
They have no internal anchor and seek no deeper meaning.
They're entirely reactive.
Right.
They aren't locked into a lower caste by divine decree.
By refusing to seek the inner meaning, they simply aren't on the map.
The hierarchy of knowledge is strictly for those walking the path.
You are either the arrived scholar or the dedicated seeker.
The latter is real.
The highest rung cannot be transferred, only earned.
And that brings us right back to the central tension of the text.
I have to push back a third time representing the disciple here.
I don't buy that yet.
If the highest rung can't be transferred, what's the teacher actually doing?
It's a fair question.
If I am a seeker and I find a sanctified scholar who has reached that angelic rung, what use is their immense knowledge if they can't hand it to me?
Why have a master at all?
It's the ultimate question of education versus transformation.
And the text answers this with the brilliant analogy of a farmer.
Consider the biological relationship between a farmer and a crop.
The teacher is like that farmer.
What is the farmer's actual job?
They fertilize the soil.
They plant the seed in the exact right conditions.
They water the earth.
They tirelessly pull the weeds.
Right, they do absolutely everything required to create the perfect environment.
They tend the field flawlessly.
But, and this is the absolute crux of the argument, the farmer cannot make the plant grow.
the actual biological mechanism of germination, the pushing of the green stock through the dark soil that is completely out of the farmer's hands.
So the teacher gives you the flawless instruction, the life-giving water, but the internal growth is entirely your own.
Precisely.
The burden of transformation falls entirely on the seeker.
The master provides the environment, but the disciple must do the growing.
The text states unequivocally that climbing requires intense, deliberate action from the seeker.
It requires deep spiritual mindfulness.
And, you know, practical, right action in the world.
Yes, it demands aqua.
And it requires that tangible action you mentioned.
Because the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family and his Allah are the disciples' Allah.
Exactly.
There is no undeserved bond of nearness.
You do not get a shortcut just because you sit near a great teacher.
So that Alam al-Sadi is non-negotiable.
I can see the argument here.
When you view it through the lens of agriculture, it is undeniable.
The farmer can create the most perfect conditions on earth, but the biological reality of growth happens
happens invisibly within the seed itself.
The harvest can never simply be handed over.
It must be grown from within.
The teacher tends, the teacher never transfers.
So we've built this massive awe-inspiring architecture.
We've mapped the outer, the inner, and the innermost.
We've seen the necessity of the teacher and the uncompromising responsibility of the seeker.
What are the ultimate stakes of this entire system?
The stakes are literally life and death, but on a spiritual plane.
The text lays it out by commanding the disciple to hold tightly to the rope of Allah.
This is a direct invocation of chapter 3, verse 103.
The text warns that without holding to that specific rope, a person will drown in the floods of ignorance.
Just as fatally as a person without a ship grounds in a physical raging ocean, it is a terrifying image.
The idea that the default state of the world isn't neutral ground, but a chaotic flood of ignorance.
You desperately need a structural ship to survive it.
And this specific discipline provides a very exact Ismaili interpretation of what that saving rope actually is.
In this reading, the imam is the outer aspect of that rope.
But crucially, you do not just leap up and grab the rope on your own.
No, it is reached strictly and systematically through intermediaries.
First you approach through the proof, and then you have to go through the gateway.
So the architecture holds all the way to the very end.
It does.
You can't bypass the hujja and you can't bypass the bob.
The structure is absolute.
And the disciple in the text
Having finally absorbed this immense structure of the cosmos, having understood the nested layers of reality and their own terrifying responsibility to climb, recites the ultimate realization.
The recognition that there is no power and no strength except through Allah.
It's the perfect culmination.
They speak that beautiful closing formula, which really captures the sheer weight of the climb.
The ladder is real.
The highest rung cannot be transferred, only earned.
The only question that matters now.
Look at your own life, your own practices, your own seeking.
Which rung have you been treating as transferable when it must be earned?